you said that acting allows you to be
many things that in your personal life
you may not be able to be but on camera
you can be that maybe I'm paraphrasing a
bit well I think we're all of us are
everything and people say why can you
say that I'm a woman with a child I'm
not a murderer okay
suppose somebody just came up and made
sure a baby in the head with a hammer
what would you call your response to
that if you picked that hammer up no
one's saying you're a murderer no one's
saying you're anything but you're
everything and if you're hired to do a
job the director does not hire you to
act like that person
the director hires you to become that
person and that's something that most
people understand about acting acting is
not I don't that word is annoying
because it means you're pretending
acting is not pretending
acting is becoming it's surrendering to
the spirit of whatever you're that
character you're describing is so thing
called stage fright that's when you're
in the middle you've given part of
yourself up to be the character but your
ego and your fear and paranoia is
watching how you give it up and tries to
control the shape of that giving up but
real actors like the ones that I adore
the Kate Winslet's and the Meryl
Streep's and the denzel's when he's
really in it and the Sam Jackson's and
philip Seymour Hoffman's and the Jeffrey
writes and when those people go there
there's no there's nobody there except
that character and that's admirable it
takes courage and people to understand
because sometimes you're not control
you're you're you want a ride if the
trust and the person you trust the
director to say that I ride right what
do you think cuz you don't stand outside
and look at your ride you ride and
that's what real great actors do philip
Seymour Hoffman's when my favorite
actress of all time I think he was
brilliant
can someone still be great and have
stage fright they can be great and have
stage fright making me really good at
have stage fright but to surrender
totally to the moment and to totally
respond to what the other person that
you're acting with is doing that's a
that takes courage you're not watching
yourself anymore you're watching the
person you're with and the scene you're
not watching how you react to what they
do you're responding it like we're
talking right now I'm not trying to be a
special anything I'm just responding to
what you're asking me and that's what
acting should be so overcoming stage
fright is is less being sort of this
defiant rebel oh I don't care what they
think of me and more being so immersed
in the moment that all of that is you
don't see it
one of my great acting teachers when I
was a very young actor I asked a similar
question he said I'm gonna make it real
simple for you he said it's like falling
into darkness backward imagine just
falling into darkness backward no
control of your landing you're gonna be
caught or not just a fault everybody
said well well supposes our rock back
there or suppose there's a I don't know
no pillows and just hard floor the
writer is saying to you I want you to
fall into darkness backward I'm giving
you all the description the director and
I who the character is we've had
rehearsals and discussions about who
this perfuming being is I do not want
you to describe them to me I want you to
become them by falling into darkness
backward can you do that
you